you're lying in a hospital bed and
people can walk in and literally say the
words oh you look so good you've lost
weight
you look so healthy while you're
connected to drains and drips and that
you literally cannot survive without
if that's not diet culture i don't know
what is
i never went to a doctor about it
because i felt like i never
got very thin so it felt like it was
never
a problem you hear your fat it just
destroys your whole self really
nobody wants to be fat now do they
i was anorexic i spent a large portion
of my late teens being clinically
terrified
of being fat you're completely numb and
your whole mind is consumed with food in
your body but even though my fears
turned into a life-threatening obsession
i'm far from the only one who has them
if you put on five pounds how would you
feel
that would be terrifying for me nineteen
percent of uk adults say they've been
disgusted by their own bodies in the
past year
eighty percent of teenage girls in the
uk say they're scared of becoming fat
and four percent of people in america
say they'd rather be blind
than overweight diet culture is um
all about control we are told
being bigger is bad i want to know why
where did this
obsession with fatness come from and
what damage is it doing
[Music]
i had a real problem with with bingeing
food
i would kind of feel really out of
control with food and i'd eat so much
that i felt very uncomfortable
and then i would occasionally
i would make myself sick
i never went to a doctor about it uh
because i felt like i never
got very thin i would kind of do it for
a few months and then i would stop
and then i would uh you know a year
later i'd do it for a few more months
and then i'd stop
i kept thinking to myself you know
you're doing all this extreme stuff
yet your body's still worse than
everyone else's and that's kind of
um you know that's where you where the
low self-esteem kind of
hits that self-esteem part
is crucial because that's where we can
get into the psychology of all of this
because i mean we all know the data we
all know
that heart disease is the biggest killer
in rich countries and that obesity
contributes to that
but that's not why i'm scared of putting
on weight
i'm scared of putting on weight because
of what it might mean about me
and because of what people might say
when i go out to a bar with a mates
according to this next guy those worries
are hardwired into us
before we're even out of nappies
from the age of three and children are
starting to report body image concerns
but they're also starting to report
stereotypes about
larger body shapes and sizes at age
three children are reporting a
perception
that people are gluttonous and slow and
as children age then the stereotypes
surround
slothfulness and having a lack of
friends become very evident within
children
around about the primary school age and
then into secondary school age
we see the stereotypes of being sexually
undesirable
being unintelligent and so on so a
three-year-old is already starting to
think about weight in a negative way
for context some milestones you can
expect at three years old
include catching a ball with both hands
jumping
and you might might become potty trained
so before you can even use the loo
you're being taught to stereotype people
because of their weight
so i would say i was around 12 years old
i went shopping and i bought my first
pair of size jeans i don't even need to
go into
sizes for some reason i have must have
picked up somewhere that this
size was a good size to be it was
acceptable it was sought after as a
young woman to be in that size g
and something clicked that day and it
was like i've got to stay this size
my eating disorder developed very very
quickly mentally i kind of just shut
down
all i would think about all day was
calories my body
exercise and the obsession just kind of
spun
further and further and further laura
was anorexic as a teenager
and now helps other people with eating
disorders i asked her where she thought
her body issues came from
it was definitely about how other people
in
body types were treated we literally are
in a world where
being in a bigger body is mocked
so you can't see it right now because
i'm fully dressed but when
i am undressed i have scars across my
body from my ankles to my stomach to the
back of my head and that was my biggest
insecurity growing up
i've had 15 surgeries before the age of
20. my health conditions
were a brain tumor a brain cyst
punctured intestines
they weren't correlated to my weight
but even though michelle's illnesses
were nothing to do with her weight
body image issues haunted her recovery
i've had the experience of nearly dying
at 11 years old
i worried about the fact that my scar
created
a fat roll which meant that no matter
what t-shirt i wear you can see this fat
roll
i was worrying about that more than the
fact that i just survived
life-saving surgery and gone through
five surgeries in a space of three
months
my concern leaving that hospital was
that i looked fat
if i think back to when my own problems
with food arose and we're literally
going back
13 14 years my first introduction to it
would have been magazines
one side they would be talking about
people with mental health problems but
the other side of it was a diet
that was my like portal into the
obsession around it and
i was constantly showing these
ridiculous photoshopped images every day
which at the time i just thought was
real life
we probably all think that our aversion
to
fat and our you know contempt
of bigger body shapes is quite a modern
phenomenon
we're going to talk to dr anna schaffner
because apparently all of this stuff
is linked to how we're doing as a
society
in periods of abundance it's a status
symbol to be
thin whereas in periods of scarcity
it's a sign of authority and power
to be bulkier when most most of the
population couldn't afford to be so
to be clear in the west we're currently
in a period of abundance
so it's a status symbol to be thin the
strongest narrative that we have
in society is that thin equals good
fat equals bad and if you are not
meeting the beauty standard
then you must spend your whole life
trying to meet it
no respite till you die all right
everybody welcome
welcome this is the first ever anti-diet
right club
online summit harry is a co-founder of
anti-diet riot club
which you guessed it campaigns against
diet culture diet culture is really
interesting
in the sense that it's often wedded to
almost
religious ideas of you know rebirth
and transcendence and purification so
it's a very
morally loaded discourse
i started running actually to the place
i was working at the time in 2015
they were offering uh london marathon
spots so i
took one i think i kind of thought it
would just change everything and i'd get
super into running and
suddenly i'd be very thin um and uh i
did get into running from from training
for marathon
um i my body didn't really change at all
we're told to believe that
people have a lot of control over their
their outcomes
and actually we know that's not true
stewart says that there's loads of
factors to do with weight that we can't
actually control
but most of us don't know that this
perception that
people are fully in control of their
weight status it doesn't align with the
literature
and i think this this message of
personal responsibility and blame
which we see is leading to negative
perceptions about people
and in particular people with obesity
how exactly are you meant to lose weight
is shame going to get you there because
frankly shame is not a long-term
solution to anything
the main comment i get online is but
you're unhealthy
and i almost want to reply well
obviously i've had 15 surgeries
occasionally it gets to me because my
medical record's so traumatic that
to say a flippant comment that like oh
but you're unhealthy
how dare you you have no clue what i've
been through
there have been quite a bit of media
that has asked the public you know is it
actually beneficial to stigmatize people
can it help
to um to solve the
obesity crisis um well it certainly
can't it's actually very
counterproductive god bless some of my
old older family members
i know they meant this with love but
they'd say don't go to the other end now
make sure you don't get too big and i'd
be thinking you've
literally just told me my worst fear
could happen
the thing is these criticisms have been
going on for
millennia in the greek period
fat was not viewed very positively
they associated fat with
animality with sluggishness with
lethargy they even banished
people of bigger sizes from from their
kingdom
and they also executed
slaves who had become too overweight
we are internalizing these messages and
so we often
start to self stigma and that's when we
start to internalize these thoughts
these feelings
and actually then that starts to impact
our own perceptions of ourself
people of size experience discrimination
in loads of different ways high body
weight is associated with fewer
employment opportunities
and stunted career advancement due to
weight related stigma
and obese patients are 65 percent more
likely to have undiagnosed medical
conditions
and that's a result of misdiagnosis or
inadequate access to healthcare
so how do you break the cycle i think
there's this idea that we all have
90 years on this earth but trust me when
when i was nearly dying at 19
all i was thinking about was all the
life experiences i missed out on because
i thought i was too fat to join in
one of the biggest body positive things
i did for myself was actually removing
all
weight conversations from working out as
soon as i realized that and i realized
that
moving my body is simply using it while
i have the opportunity to
i started paddle boarding i started
horse riding i started doing
all the things that i never did because
i thought i was too fat to do because
that's what society tells you
the moment i started doing that i had an
appreciation for my body
for simply what it does rather than what
it looks like
we are basing our whole self-worth on
this number on a scale
or you know how well our trousers fit
and it can absolutely ruin
or make a day you know you feel so great
if you've lost one pound or maintained
and absolutely like soul-crushingly bad
if you
um you know aren't losing weight rapidly
or have plateaued or have gained weight
dieting hooks into this wider
discourse of self-optimization
self-improvement ideas about the extent
to which we can self-improve and change
who we are
how we look and so on that became really
really pronounced in the 20th century
when um you know self-help as a genre
exploded
and when people you know began to think
that they can change themselves in very
fundamental way including
their physical appearance
i went to ireland and i got there and i
was very weak
and i was just exhausted and consumed
cost me a lot of energy to
walk down the street i couldn't sit in
the back of a car or i'd be in pain
i was always very cold and i was
obviously i was starving you know i used
to dream about food
people around me really reacted in a
very upset way that i hadn't seen in a
while
and i think that was when it really hit
home that something was wrong
so i had my kind of uh
breakdown or dark night of the soul
where i literally thought to myself
this is going to kill me this is going
to take my life
and there was a fleeting moment where i
accepted that
the thought of getting better was that
terrifying
luckily that was my turning point
it's kind of the first time that i
realized that uh it's okay to be
sweaty when you're uh fat you feel um
that you're sweating more than other
people you're more out of breath than
other people
um and because i i had to do this
these runs i had to do the training
because i knew that i had this big
thing at the end this big marathon at
the end and i just had to get over those
things
cool uh so uh yeah uh when's the
triathlon um
london although actually that's the
right one this is my all 2017. kind of
did that first marathon
and i still didn't feel like a runner
which is insane
um because i was running three times a
week and i'd you know i'd run a marathon
so
um you know i had a literal medal um
showing
that i was a runner but i did a
triathlon after that the next year and
then
the year after i did another marathon uh
london marathon
and um and i think after that i felt
like i was a running person that i was a
runner
after finally accepting that he is in
fact a runner
martin founded fat athletes which is a
running club for people in bigger bodies
we uh go for a weekly runs sometimes we
try different exercises like a bit of
yoga
or swimming and the idea is um
it's a group so there's kind of safety
in numbers it's just about kind of
feeling good
in the body that you have getting a bit
of sweat and having some new friends
the more time we spend in our heads
thinking about what we look like to
other people
the more time we don't live our life and
fulfill our potential and
actually love our bodies for what they
let us do every day
from my 11 year old lying in a hospital
bed
i wish i could tell her that her looking
fat
is the most unimportant thing and your
life is so much bigger than what you
look like
your life is so much bigger than your
beauty and you are so much more
than what you look like and how much you
weigh